und wie ich jetzt wieder loslegen also
komm ich werde sie das pendeln gib mir
das passieren darf ist dass pavin killen
ich will alles kaputt hauen james bond
und los geht's lasst ihr ein und erleben
durch schwarzer und wieder ein nein
leute herzlich willkommen zu eine runde
scheibe games und heute ist der tag der
tag der tage der rage heute ist die
deeskalation dran
die zweite folge auf meinem channel und
ja es wird wieder laut heute so viel ist
klar und sg sieben hier bestimmt genug
gründe rechts vom ersten keine [ __ ]
ich habe deine musik ist und wir geben
uns halt ein bisschen und 321 mutter
stefanie hoch haben einfach mal schön
einsteigt jetzt kommt dass du sohn einer
[ __ ] scheiß alter spross musste sich
bewusst dass rage mein leben kaputt hier
dies habe einige personen vergessen
haben sie denn es halt deine hessen so
eine geile scheiße ich hasse alle ich
hasse sie gebt ihr dass ich habe einfach
nur kaputt geschickt hier am spawn
wieder
ich hasse ich viele leute oder so
unbewaffnet ansporn gekillt ist einander
bis aufs maul
ja hallo hallo komm mal her mein lieber
die ich kenne ich von hinten sieht mich
wirklich kommt man und du bist dein
alter fünf punkte gebracht
ich hab gehört ich habe so ein schwert
habe ich auch schon bis auf die route
gegangen oder wie das verkraftet ich bin
runter geht
es hat geklappt war dann nicht 20 deine
pizza die alles selber machen wollen
also ich sag euch leute wenn ich dies
auf dieser eisenstadt route gehen ich
hasse es ist ja gerade ist nicht machen
weil das sind immer so 20 kleine pizza
die sich gerade erst entdeckt die kämpfe
bestimmt keine aber es sind wie gesagt
20 von 24 in dieser runde die diese ist
über tote gehen
das heißt natürlich wenn man dann auf
diesen teleporter will der einen so hoch
schießt das dann erst mal 20 spacken
allen mit der hand schlagen und wir
wissen wir diese kuren abgründe und alle
die jetzt keine keine was diese ganzen
fragen der rüstungs punkte vielleicht
hatte ich den mund nicht zu voll nehmen
scheiß drauf scheiß drauf und ich von
den arsch oder ist ein gegner zu gegner
nein es massiv behinderte geräusche
so leute da sind ja wieder und wo
sollten wir anders sein alter tews
mutter geschickten map sg siegen und ich
komm ich bekomme sich meine birne rein
geb ich das einfach hier unten
da ist einfach eine nutella kriegerin
wie kann man sich nur teller kriegerin
ein nenne ich meine an alle täter ist
ungefähr das gleiche aber ganz ehrlich
leichtlaufreifen hotel und dann wird
auch noch eine mit der themen leute als
erbärmlicher wird's nicht mehr erwerben
hier wird sicher nicht mehr
und wie ich wieder loslege na komm ich
werde sie das pendeln gib mir dass ich
will alles kaputt hauen james bond und
los geht's los geht's am leben durch
schwarzer und wieder lächelt nein nein
nein
ich bin links schlagen
er boxt mich runter diese kleine chance
nicht bekommen
bist du mich verarschen eigentlich
verarschen
er hat mir ja was kommt zu mir kommst du
dir hab mir kommen zu dir selbst man
finde deine innere mit dem spaß alles
mit dieser holstein gibt merkel nein
nein nein nein
hat ein landwirt japan wenn es die
christen
den finger in new mexico laster und
kommentar während places bitte machen
dies deutlich geheim geheimnis sein